liberal calls for a boycott of Goya
foods prompting president Trump and his
daughter Ivanka to post on social media
supporting the company it has CNN very
upset take a look you tell me how a
president in the middle of a pandemic
has got time for this book are you
kidding me
Hawking products are going I don't care
who it is resolute desk this is what
he's resolute about we're in a public
health battle for our lives and our
futures and the president is sitting
there behind the resolute desk
resolutely clutching and beans Dan bonds
you know why is it so impossible for the
mainstream media to focus on the real
issue well I mean their mainstream media
they're just embarrassing buffoons I
mean look at those two I mean Chris
Palmer I'm super surprised he's not
doing tricep curls at his desk but these
liberal boycotts are always an
embarrassing failure
remember the chick-fil-a boycott you
couldn't get a chicken sandwich for 47
square miles in my neighborhood after
the alleged boycott you can't find a a
black beans can anywhere in my local
neighborhood after their so-called
boycott but there's a reason and the
reason is the liberals who allegedly
boycott these you know sit in their
basements and have no jobs and watch
Teletubbies videos all day unemployed
roasting s'mores so they have no buying
power while conservatives who have jobs
will go out and support people who stand
up for the United States
so these boycotts are always a hilarious
bust and they're they're kind of fun to
watch these idiots implode Dana what are
the larger consequences here well it
depends I mean it is possible as dan
says that the Goya could become the new
chick-fil-a and so cows everywhere will
continue to be happy but I do think that
there's a possibility here that after
the election after this is no longer
useful to anybody politically that there
are long term possible consequences for
the company that has 4,000 employees so
there's that and then the other thing is
I do think that this is a company that
has done incredible charitable work for
Latinos and especially in the time of
the pan
demmick making sure that they were out
there providing food whatever else was
needed in the Latino community like very
very much focused on that and when the
Liberals and these other liberal groups
try to go after this company for
expressing you know a First Amendment
right with the president and being
grateful for having been there then I do
think you have to look back and say what
have you done for the Latino community
how many how many Latinos are on your
board because it's a hundred percent
Latinos on the goya board you know so I
think that if people trying to make
political hay out of it you have to
understand that there could be long-term
consequences but those on the left
trying to hurt Goa they're actually just
biting off their nose despite their face
mm-hmm one I had the pleasure of
interviewing the Goya food CEO on Fox &
Friends and he shared with me that when
Michelle Obama then first lady invited
him to the White House to work with her
he accepted and also he accepted the
Trump administration's invitation to
attend the White House
why is respecting the office of the
presidency such a deal-breaker for
Democrats I don't think it's just them
because I think it's specifically
Latinos and maybe most of all Mexican
Americans who feel that the president
has attacked immigrants from Mexico you
know demean them mock them call them
names I think there's the reason but
look in this instance you know why is it
that owning the lives and culture wars
is more important than anything to the
president why is it more important than
dealing with the pandemic I just don't
get it I think that putting those canes
there holding a can of beans like he's
the king of the world I mean it seems to
me misplaced priorities in the in this
current pandemic Jesse what are your
thoughts trumps defending Mexican food
really CNN's upset about that I thought
CNN said he hates Mexicans and now
they're upset because he's defending
Mexican food which one is it CNN I mean
and liberals are the ones boycotting
Mexican food it's like it everything's
up and daddy can't make sense